what I'd like to do today is talk a
little bit more about what companies can
do to reduce the damages that they cause
to avoid or mitigate risks and also on
the plus side what are the opportunities
for businesses to make money or improve
their their performance by conserving
biodiversity or supplying ecosystem
services or restoring ecosystems as the
case may be there's an old saying I
think where there's muck there's brass I
don't know where that comes from the UK
probably but the idea is that there's
always a business opportunity even in
something that seems very unlikely such
as a mess in the forest so let's first
of all look at the the mitigation side
what can companies do to reduce damages
and there are many many tools that have
been developed over the last few years I
don't have time to go into all of them
but broadly I think you can categorize
the different approaches to helping
businesses first of all avoid negative
impacts secondly reducing those impacts
or mitigating them and thirdly verifying
how well they're doing this I want to
quickly go through some of the other
opportunities that are there there are
many and this is one report among
several in the last few years that have
tried to identify how do you create
business value from conserving
biodiversity or providing ecosystem
services whether that's adding
biodiversity to an existing business
line or establishing entirely new
markets and so on the bottom right
you've got the examples of bio carbon
and red plus or water quality trading
biodiversity banking which I've referred
to where you're not just adding
biodiversity to something that an
existing product or service but creating
an entirely new sector
you